[Musik]
die agro hat gefragt wie man sich einen
effektiven gegen mückenstiche schönsten
sehr kritische fragen 'wie ein bisschen
auszuholen
die scarecrow richtig schreibt sind nur
weibliche mücken fiese blutsauger dabei
ernähren sie stechmücken sowie viele
anderen säcken auch eigentlich von
pflanzen legte und frucht setzen nur
wenn die weibchen gerade ihren
offizieren brauchen sie blut um diese zu
entwickeln
und jetzt müsst ihr kurz stark sein denn
es wird jetzt gleich brutal eklig wenn
ich euch zeige was mücken genau mit uns
machen dass freunde der sonne ist ein
mücken risse hier in eurem gewebe herum
die teure blutgefäß geführt hat und dann
darin herum sagt stich beschreibt ihr
eigentlich noch den besten teil dieser
ganzen katastrophe nach dem eigentlichen
stichwort und sagte mücke nämlich im
schnitt vier minuten an äußerung tier
minuten nicht hier voll aber das ist
noch nicht genug für das haben die
unverschämtheit in unser blut zu spucken
sanitäts noch der grund für diese
respektlosigkeit ist folgender unsere
blutgefäße sind auch nicht dumm wenn da
jemand kommt und in ihnen herumstochert
gerinnt das blut damit es nicht immerhin
läuft deswegen initiative über ihren
speicher sogenannte antikoagulanzien
also blutverdünnungsmittel damit sie in
ruhe in die rohstoffe und herum so brune
festzustecken
das ist jetzt alles sehr eklig aber das
stechen herumstochern und saugen ist gar
nicht das eigentliche problem sondern
das problem ist dass die meisten
menschen allergisch gegen mücken spucke
wind was passiert also unser immunsystem
bekommt panik wenn unser körper mit
einem allergen konfrontiert wird
produziert er gestern
dieses kleine unscheinbare moleküls ist
das eigentliche problem dieses ganzen
mücken dramas weil bisher zu erhöhen
das blut zusammen mit besonders vielen
weißen körperchen strömt zur
gefahrenstelle möglich die folgen sind
rötungen schwellungen und jucken
das wäre ja alles sehr nett wenn mögen
stiche irgendwie gefährlich wären sind
sie aber nicht wohnt hier den send nicht
leiden ist einfach nur eine völlige
überreaktion unseres eigenen
immunsystems das unbedingt beschützen
möchte natürlich die mücke übertreten
irgendwelche gefährlichen krankheiten
aber auch da hilft eine
entzündungsreaktion nicht wirklich
weiter toll
danke immunsystem aber wie kann man sich
denn jetzt vor mückenstichen schützen
und jetzt wisst ihr noch mal stark sein
denn es ist praktisch unmöglich diesen
viechern zu entgehen die dinge können
sich anhand des co2 das beim ausatmen
aus einer entfernung von 50 metern
aufspüren die effektivste maßnahme gegen
müssen wäre also nicht mehr zu atmen
kann ich nicht empfehlen und auch zu
anti mücken sprays hat die forschung
eine deprimierende entdeckung gemacht
déi et ist der wirksamste anti mücken
schutz weil sein geruch mücken ab stößt
allerdings haben forscher beobachtet
dass immer mehr mücken resistent dagegen
werden und ich habe noch einen dollar
für euch abends beim lüften das licht
auszumachen damit die mücken nicht
reinkommen soll auch nicht besonders die
hilfen des geraubten forscher da sich
mücken im gegensatz zu vielen anderen
insekten weniger am licht orientieren
sondern mehr an geruch und wärme
am ende hilft und auch nur noch seine
haut mit möglichst lange klamotten zu
bedecken müssen gitter anzubringen oder
unter einem moskitonetz zu schlafen und
ich hin falls benutzer auch insekten
spricht denn es gibt ja noch den knoten
gegen die das wirksam ist cheney hinzu
zufolge jetzt hier ein bisschen zu
deprimierend war
ich hätte zumindest noch ein party zwar
nicht gegen möglich an sich sondern wie
man am besten damit umgeht wenn man halt
mal schon welche hat also ich selbst hat
jetzt nach dem urlaub geht 18 stück und
wir so ich jedenfalls weiß ich das noch
interessiert dann könnt ihr das in die
kommentare schreiben
zusammen mit euren fragen bewegen uns
erstmal bleibt sicher